and then we go the recording's on
well good morning and welcome everybody
and thank you for attending this
morning's
webinar to find out more about higher
and degree level apprenticeships
i'm carolyn renick and i'm the cabinet
member for economic growth at
north east derbyshire district council
and my team and in particular jane
weston our senior employment
skills officer have recently developed
and launched the district's first
employment and skills policy and whilst
it's not the
district's statutory duty to provide
education and skills specifically we
did feel strongly that this council
played its part in the
leveling up agenda and as part of our
new growth strategy we are doing
significant amount of regeneration
across northeast arbitration
for example we've just been awarded just
short of 25 million
for the clay crosstown deal with just
one of one of 101
towns looking enough to win this funding
and this will see the creation of a
skills hub
a creative work sector hundreds of new
jobs across
clay cross alone and with the amount of
new housing
business premises we need dozens of jobs
in the construction centre alone and we
are working on a skills bit to try and
support this sector specifically
apprenticeships are largely driven by
the need to fill the skills gap
and they're a great way to upskill
existing staff and indeed
recruit new staff and they provide
actual
hands-on or on-the-job training and
experience and i think
this gives some some people a much
better understanding of an industry
and actual work ethic and it's also
without the colossal debts
from tuition fees i also believe
it widens the net for a greater talent
pool and
brilliant opportunities for some people
young actually
indeed older people to acquire skills
knowledge opportunities and jobs
where more formal routes don't seem to
suit
i'm actually a huge fan of
apprenticeships and really pleased that
they now provide our workforce with
higher level qualifications too
and i'm thrilled today that our panel
have a wealth of experience
and also a passion for supporting
apprenticeships
so our panel today we have from the
university of derby we have andy dowling
who worked in sales and marketing for
over 20 years in both the private and
public sector
he's worked at the university for almost
10 years leading on business development
for work-based learning programs and
apprenticeships
and since 2017 andy has grown the
apprenticeship numbers at the university
from
around 150 to now 1450
so huge congratulations andy and welcome
we also have spencer ryan pruitt who's
an award-winning
economic regeneration specialist who
secured and managed the delivery over
100 million of business support growth
and training and development projects in
the uk
europe and north america having led
programs supporting over 20 000 small
and medium enterprises
spence was appointed to a united nations
advisory group for crime prevention and
counterterrorism
the specific focus around dissemination
and training to small and medium
enterprises
with a passion for supporting business
growth job creation and economic
prosperity
spencer is currently academic lead for
business management and leadership
degree apprenticeships at the university
of derby welcome to you spencer
that's a hugely impressive cv there and
finally we have lee barnes who's the
managing director of inspired design and
development
lee's a civil engineer by qualification
and established
inspires consulting engineering practice
following a successful
freelance career he has built a
successful team of engineers that range
from
17 to 70 years old and is keen to
provide continuous education
and professional development
opportunities for all team members
hugely laudable lee and welcome to you
finally i'd just like to introduce um
maria who's also with us today she's an
intern
at north east derbyshire district
council and has organised this event so
thank you maria
i have to say i've been hugely impressed
by maria and in fact all are
entertainers have joined the district
this year
they are super bright super cool dynamic
confident and bring a new dimension to
our teams with a fresher young
perspective
so thank you maria it's a pleasure to
work with you and thank you also
to jane weston who's done decades of
work for us
across the district on our school she's
really our skills champion
so without further ado i'll hand over to
andy and
spencer to talk to you about the higher
and degree level apprenticeships and
their
sort of flexible offer and hopefully
we'll hear them from lee from
inspire design who will talk about the
benefits of higher
and degree level upon shifts and his own
staffs experience
hopefully a quick q a session and
then hopefully we'll then sum up in
about an hour's time
over to you now andy thank you
morning all um so thanks very much for
the
uh introductions counsellor uh so yeah
funny enough with uh
from with lee uh we've already got two
apprentices
with uh with lee's company already and
i'm sure lee might go through that
later on in his presentation uh but just
to provide you with
um an overview um so i'm just trying to
go on to the next slide oh yeah uh so to
just provide you with an overview of
apprenticeships first of all at the
university of derby
uh so we've been delivering higher
apprenticeships and degree
apprenticeships
uh since uh for a while now we started
with higher apprenticeships in 2012
when there was actual hefty money uh
desired
that we could draw on to develop higher
apprenticeships we started
apprenticeships in minerals and also in
nursing as well
they successfully grew and grew and grew
which was great and we formed very
strong
links with local employers all over
uh derbyshire nottinghamshire and and
really across
across england to be honest um since
2012
we've grown from circa well initially we
had around 150 apprentices
now we've got 1700 apprentices across
our group so we've got when i say our
group
we've got the university of derby and
also buxton lee college
as well so we've got 1450
circa roughly uh within the university
and the remainder at our college what
we've done is
is worked with all of our
local and national employees to look at
the apprenticeships
and the skills gaps and the issues that
they're looking at
to address within their businesses so
really we have
apprenticeships in in main themes around
management engineering
nursing teaching policing and minerals
really so they're the main
main areas that we're very strong in
public sector has always been a
massive area for the university uh about
80 percent of our apprentices
come from the public sector in in some
sort of role really
so what my next side really i just
wanted to go
through what is an apprenticeship i know
majority people know what an
apprenticeship is but it's sometimes
good just to
just to highlight what it is it is a
system of training a new generation
it's it's job role related as well
that's the most important that's what i
always say
first and foremost it's a job role and
it's designed to support somebody to
develop their skills
their knowledge
so it combines work and study and the
earn while you learn is really important
as well with an apprenticeship
and it's interesting that uh we've got a
give the example of
the civil engineer degree apprenticeship
which i'm going to touch on in a minute
or two
we've got lots of civil engineers
obviously started fresh within their
businesses three or four years ago
and are now three to four years into
their their degree apprenticeship on
civils
and let's say one of their friends who's
gone to universities just to do a civil
engineering degree
it's going to be interesting in a few
years time when they both graduate
to see who's got the most experience and
you can guarantee it's going to be the
apprentice
because they've got obviously the
on-the-job training as well so
with with apprenticeships you've got the
off-the-job element so typically it's a
day a week that you've released to learn
about those knowledge skills and
behaviors for the apprenticeship and
then you've got that 80
on the job experience that you're
learning on a day-to-day basis as well
which is really important
it's it's training in skills that
employers want as well
which which so all apprenticeships have
have been developed by employers as well
which is great
uh so they're all employer-driven they
provide excellent progression
opportunities we've got
loads of case studies and examples now
where our apprentices have actually
been promoted as a result of an element
of the apprenticeship that they've been
been doing certainly increased future
earning potential i think like i
mentioned
at the start you you're obviously
employed as well
four or five years in so once you've
completed your your degree
apprenticeship
you've you've got that experience on the
job you've got the qualification
and the chances are you're gonna have a
stronger career as a result
you can also study on an apprenticeship
at your own pace
you know apprenticeships are designed
for all
uh you can be studying it part-time as
well we've got part-timers
we've got various different scenarios
that we can certainly explore with
individuals
to ensure that they can completely 20
off the job training
in their own time so just to provide you
with an overview of the apprenticeships
that we have
within the wider university um i know
spencer in a minute or two is going to
discuss the operation
operations and departmental manager as
well as the chartered manager degree
apprenticeship
and i'm going to go through some of the
engineering apprenticeships that we
that we have we're just to touch on
those areas and themes that i uh
mentioned at the start as you can see
nursing
teaching policing or all in all in there
as well as the engineering and
management
now 20 off the job training um
just touched on it a minute or two ago
uh a lot of a lot of employers look at
it and think oh my gosh
i'm going to lose somebody a day a week
how's that going to impact on on
my business uh what we try and do is is
work with you
the employer to to to develop a learning
plan
that's bespoke um we're very creative
with our 20
off the job training and how how we
deliver
that uh spencer again we'll we'll go
through
some of the blended approaches to how we
deliver the operations departmental
manager
and also the chartered manager in a
minute or two but this line just
provides you with
some of the examples that can go towards
the off-the-job training
so you know stuff like site visits uh
where you go to another site
possibly within your business or could
it be a client site
you're learning new knowledge skills and
behaviors there
shadowing as well so let's say um
as an apprentice your your manager goes
away
and you you know for on annual leave and
you take on some of their
responsibilities
that's new knowledge skills and
behaviors you know and you're doing them
on the job as well which is which is
great the workplace mentoring
is is so important as well to give
that individual when they're doing the
20 off the job training exposure
to various departments within within
their uh
within the employer to get those
knowledge skills and behaviors
you can the 20 includes simulations role
play which you can be doing
both on the on the job uh so you're
applying some of the knowledge skills
and behaviors that you've learned
into your working role um as well as
your standard stuff like lectures and
seminars and online learning because i
think a lot of people just think of it
as as that
it's going to be someone that's someone
sitting in a classroom and it's not
the other big thing is the assessment
preparation which again i'm sure spencer
will go through
in a bit uh as providing some examples
that he has with some of his apprentices
so just to touch on the engineering
theme um
so what i wanted to do is promote two
engineering apprenticeships that we
currently deliver within the university
which might be of interest to the wider
employers in in northeast derbyshire
district council
area so the first one is the
manufacturing engineer degree
apprenticeship
so we started this one a few years ago
actually working very closely with
jcb on it and we've now got
uh employers from really i would say
planes trains
diggers and automobiles as well on it
a mixture of different employers which
is great and they're sending us
apprentices regularly
obviously they've got their diff their
different sectors and all of their
apprentices are able to share
knowledge and skills with different
apprentices from different employees
which is really great
uh so typically the apprenticeship lasts
for 60
months we have i think called a
practical period which tends to be about
48 months so the practical period is
where actually
you're learning the knowledge skills and
behaviors for the apprenticeship so
you're learning that on a weekly basis
through that 20
off the job training and typically with
higher and degree apprenticeships
we we always map a university recognized
qualification to them as well
so so the off the training and the
practical periods is when you're doing
that degree element as well
so as i mentioned that's typically 48
months
you've then got a further 12 months to
prepare and get ready for that endpoint
assessment
so after you've done the 48 months you
get to a thing called the gateway point
where we review that you've done your
degree if there's a functional skills
requirement as well
and also we're also ensuring that your
e-portfolio
which is where where you're uploading
those knowledge skills and behaviors
evidence too
is is all up to date and ready so
typically 60 months
for the manufacturing engineer degree
apprenticeship
so what we've done is we've mapped
b n qualifications to this
apprenticeship as well
so as i mentioned we've got employers
from planes trains automobiles and
diggers in on this apprenticeship
they send us engineer engineers from
who want to look at different
disciplines within engineering so they
could go down
a straight manufacturing pathway as you
can see
or they can they can look at the
mechanical design with manufacturing
or also if they wanted to specialize in
electronics they've got that as an
option as well
now the structure as you can see how it
how it works over that sort of 48 month
period
uh so the credits is what you're sort of
studying
uh for the the degree element and when
you're doing those credits you're also
building up those knowledge skills and
behaviors
that you upload to that endpoint
assessment as well
so that's really the manufacturing
engineer degree apprenticeship
now we also run the civil engineer
degree apprenticeship which uh lee does
have an apprentice with us
currently which is really great um so i
just want to say
the definition from our head of
apprenticeships for engineering
angela dean who unfortunately couldn't
make it today but
she was talking about this program as
being suitable for engineers
undertake design feasibility project
planning
or site work for projects operations in
road whale
water infrastructure management
including safety and quality checks
the embedded degree which has been
mapped to the apprenticeship
as well again very similar to the
manufacturing engineer degree
apprenticeship while you're studying
that
you're also building up those knowledge
skills and behaviors
as well getting ready for that endpoint
assessment at the end
now the the civil engineer is heavy
aligned with with the
institute of civil engineers you can
gain
incorporated engineer status through
that endpoint assessment
as well again it's a 48-month practical
period for this apprenticeship very
similar to the manufacturing one
with that 12-month element to get you
ready for that end point assessment
so there's a lot of a practical element
it's both on the manufacturing engineer
and also on the civil engineer
so you tend to find with engineering
apprenticeships
there probably is a little bit more face
to face than
uh than than probably a typical
management apprenticeship but as you can
imagine
there is obviously a lot a lot of
technical knowledge and skills that need
to be
passed on and embedded so it's it's so
it's important
that we can get the apprentices on site
to be able to
to utilize some of the facilities and
apply that learning
so the other thing is it so we've got
and i mentioned about the e-portfolios
that we use
so across the university that our main
e-portfolio is smart assessor
for the civil engineer we also have to
use the institute for civil engineers
um portal as well to upload the
knowledge skills and behavior so there's
two
e-portfolios uh linked to this
apprenticeship
so i just wanted to also said so this
provides you with
an overview of the degree for the civil
engineer as well
similar to structure really to the
manufacturing engineer
where you study various credits over
various years
there are different modules that you can
contextualize
to your own employer's needs as well
which is great as you can see there's an
independent project
at level six as well that you can that
you can study on
we started the civil engineer degree
apprenticeship four years ago
uh we've now got over a hundred
apprentices
on that apprenticeship so it's been very
successful
so far and now we're starting to get
apprentices going through endpoint
assessment as well which is very
exciting
now just to highlight the facilities
that we have
from an engineering perspective so if so
three years ago we we opened our stem
facility uh based at our marketing
campus
in in derby uh it has a various
um various different rooms and different
areas to specialize in the various
themes
for engineering obviously focusing on
stem subjects
it should be really good if any any
employer locally within the
northeast derbyshire area would like to
to come down and view some of those that
equipment and facilities we can
certainly
uh we can certainly facilitate that
so now just moving on to to spencer
morning everybody thanks for andy and
are you happy to progress the slides
yeah you need to click when uh when you
need to
bless you thank you very much morning
everybody thanks for andy
um and thank you for the invite over
today
uh my name is spencer i'm the academic
lead for management apprenticeships at
the university of derby
so what i'd like to do over this next
slot if you like is to talk you through
the
management apprenticeship
apprenticeships that we have at derby
and again it's uh it's great to see to
see lee in the group this morning as
well having uh
one of his team actually on one of my
programs as well so that's uh
that's really good as well so first and
foremost on the screen you can see here
a bit of an overview and description of
degree apprenticeships
so principally it combines the two
elements of that academic knowledge
element
whereby you're learning about models
theories tools and concepts
relating to management and uh
and the underpinning behind what those
things mean
why they work what they're for what the
principle is behind them
and then that professional competence
element that lifts those theories and
tools and concepts
and gives you the opportunity to test
them and use them
and utilize them within your role for
your development for the development of
your team and ultimately for the
development of the organization
as a whole so it's combining those
things
and this is what we refer to as an
applied management project
it's not just about being able to learn
and repeat theory
it's being able to learn about
management concepts and actually utilize
them to help you develop in your role
and help your organization develop as
part of that
that return on investment i guess really
that the that your employer makes into
uh the time and the financial investment
that's undertaken in in supporting team
members to
undertake a degree apprenticeship like
this
thank you andy if you leave it on please
excuse me
so at the university of derby as andy's
mentioned
we have coupled the apprenticeship to
university qualifications
and these are what we term with dual
awards and principally what that means
is that
for the programs that i'll i'll be
describing to you in more detail in a
moment
you undertake academic modules of
learning within the university
and the outcome of those academic
modules of learning within the
university
is you will either end up with a
foundation degree in business management
and leadership
or you will end up with a degree in
business management and leadership
now because this is an apprenticeship
program we've mapped
our degree programs to the chartered
management institute
assessment criteria for the operations
and departmental manager
apprenticeship and also the chartered
manager degree apprenticeship
so in effect in undertaking these
apprenticeship programs
you end up with two foundation level
qualification foundation degree level
qualifications
or two degree level qualifications
depending on the program that you
that you join so if you join the
foundation
degree program you end up with a
foundation degree
for operations departmental managers
business management and leadership
and you also end up with a level five
diploma from the chartered management
institute
and in that sense they are effectively
because we're talking about level five
qualifications
they are uh they are there is a parity
between them
so you end up with literally two
qualifications at that level
for the degree level you have the chart
of manager
degree apprenticeship diploma which is
level six and you also have the full
degree
from the university of derby in business
management and leadership
now alongside those because you're
undertaking level 5 and level 6
qualifications with the chartered
management institute
you are also
credited with chartered manager status
from the charter management
institute and it's very similar to how
you hear of other chartered
status chartered accountant chartered
surveyor
it's a it's a recognition of your status
and competence and capability
as a manager within within your
organization having undertaken these
qualifications
thanks andy if you just uh move it on
for me
thank you so principally then we have
two core qualifications that uh that
fall within my program area
and as you can see although there's
there's four elements on the screen
there i'll explain that in a bit more
detail in a moment
so we have the foundation degree in
business management and leadership and
that's coupled as i said a moment ago
with the level five uh diploma for
operations of
departmental managers that program takes
27 to 30 months
because the academic modules behind the
equate to two years and then we add
three to six months onto the end of that
to uh facilitate the gateway process
to lead to end point assessment now for
those of you who aren't familiar with
endpoint assessment
principally it's an external assessment
that's undertaken independently from the
university
and it's the mandatory part of passing
the apprenticeship
as far as the government uh the
government funding behind levien
and suchlike is concerned so as i say
the foundation degree is a 27 to 30
month program on that basis
the charter manager degree
apprenticeship as you can see we have
three different versions of it here
when i say different versions it's
purely in relation to the entry
point so overall
we we can support individuals to join
the program
at levels four five or six and the basis
of those entry points
is to recognize prior qualifications
prior professional experience that
enables us
to credit you with
with that experience or that
qualification to join the program at a
higher level on that basis
and as you can see the level 4 entry
point is 51 to 54 months
in exactly the same way as the uh the
foundation degree
so it's a it's a four year program with
three to six months on the end for
gateway and endpoint assessment
uh the level five entry point as you can
see in the middle there is 39 to 42
months
so it's a three year program with three
six months for
gateway and endpoint assessment and the
level six top up
is 27 to 30 months in exactly the same
way again
two years for the academic modules with
three to six months for
uh gateway and endpoint assessment
thanks andy
so moving on in terms of actual
structure then for the
operations in departmental manager what
you're seeing on the screen here is a
typical
uh typical structure that we would uh
undertake as part of that
program the university of derby online
learning which is
what my team is part of we actually run
and operate
three terms a year rather than the
traditional on campus
two terms a year and the reason for that
is because
we recognize that actually as
in most cases full-time employees
undertaking a degree level program as
well
you have a full-time job to do you have
homes and families to
see and run and keep keep operating
in addition to the fact that you you
probably would like some down time and
some leisure time and some time to be
able to relax
so in in structuring our program around
three turns
it gives us the opportunity first and
foremost to concentrate on one subject
area per term
now for full-time on-campus university
students
they can be studying three or four
different subject areas every time
now recognizing as i said that that fact
that
a lot of the students are working
full-time home lives family lives and
having the opportunity to relax
we find that structure around just
having
one core subject area per term works
best in terms of
um giving giving that ability to be able
to study
effectively alongside everything else
that's going on in in people's lives
but also it gives the opportunity to
really focus and drill down on a
specific subject area
for that term and in doing so it gives
us the best opportunity then to identify
with each student
how they can utilize that information
that they're learning within their role
and within their
organization for the the personal
benefit of getting a better
understanding of the organization
developing further academically and also
improving their performance their
behavior in the workplace
as a result terms are on
september january and may
and we do intakes generally of new
students in september and january
it's not very often we'll do an intake
in may if i'm completely honest
but those are the those are the periods
that we run september january and may
for
for term times and uh intakes in
september and january
so as i say what you can see on the
screen here is the typical program
structure for the level five operations
and departmental manager apprenticeship
thank you andy
moving on then to the chartered manager
degree apprenticeship
so what you can see on the screen now is
now the four-year program
operates in the in the same way as the
operational departmental manager in the
sense that
we have a dedicated subject per term
three terms per year
the only difference is it's over a four
year program the exception on this
particular program
is the final two terms where you can see
in the bottom right hand corner there
professional review and business impact
project
professional review is uh part
reflective
so it looks back on the development of
the individual
over the entirety of the program that
they've been on
it's also part engaging
their their analysis
and their reflection into what that
actually means for them in the
organization what it means to the team
around them within the organization what
it means to the employers within the
organization
whereby part of that process is they
will undertake a 360 degree review
they will reflect that against the
learning that they've undertaken they
will put together a
forward plan in terms of their
development and and look at
and consider how they can further
progress
everything that they've learned coming
out of the program into that development
of themselves and team
their teams in the organization the
business impact project
is i suppose it it does what it says on
the tin really it's a project that's
undertaken within the organization
that is designed to have a positive and
hopefully significant
benefit to the organization within the
apprenticeship program the business
impact project is the nearest hour
students will get to undertaking a
dissertation
and that's why that particular module is
delivered over two terms
because as part of that process the
students will identify an organizational
issue they want to improve or develop or
or introduce even with the agreement and
support of the employer
they will devise a project to address
that issue
they will actually then deliver and
fully evaluate that project
over approximately eight months
now the important part about that
project is well it's
i guess multifaceted really in the sense
that it gives the
students the opportunity to really
understand project management because we
take them through the project management
tools theories models and concepts it
gives them the opportunity to apply that
learning
in the delivery of the project that they
undertake from the employer perspective
it's delivering an immediate positive
outcome
because it's about a live project within
the employer
and actually it's also crucial as far as
the end point assessment is concerned
because that project
is assessed independently as part of the
endpoint assessment
and the students actually have to
present that project as part of the
endpoint assessment
so it fulfills a lot of functions within
the
within the development of the individual
over the program as a whole
thank you andy so similar again i do
apologize
um similar again the uh the structure of
the
level five entry point is is very very
similar
um in effect this this model that you
see on the screen now
is exactly the same as the previous one
with the removal of the level four
modules
in in simplicity uh thank you andy if
you go again
and then finally this is the level six
top up that you're looking at at the
moment
and in a similar way to what i've just
described previously
this is effectively a level six entry
point so
students coming onto this program will
have uh previous qualifications perhaps
at level four
five possibly six um and and more
significant
operational professional experience as
well
now the question that we usually asked
at this point is
um how how is it determined
which entry point a student will join
the program at
so the process that we have to go
through is that every student will
undertake
what we term as a skill scan in relation
to
the knowledge skills and behaviors
associated with the qualification
i know andy's mentioned the knowledge
skills and behaviors a few times in his
presentation there
the knowledge skills and behaviors are
the criteria that we have to meet
we have to demonstrate that you meet as
a student in
in passing the apprenticeship as a whole
so we undertake a skill scan right at
the very beginning of the program
whereby we identify
individual competencies against each of
those knowledge skills and behaviors
we look at previous work experience we
look at previous qualifications
and we also undertake an interview with
every prospective student for the
program
the combination of those things and from
our
history and experience in delivering the
program gives us the ability to provide
the best possible advice in terms of the
entry point for
students onto the program that's
effectively the mechanism that we
utilize that determines
whether we will offer a place at level 4
level 5 or level 6 entry points thank
you andy
so looking at that then at how that
actually operates on a turn-by-turn
basis
so as i've said each each term is a
dedicated specific individual module
and the module breaks down as you can
see on the screen here
so for a few weeks prior to the module
actually starting
students will have access to our virtual
learning environment called blackboard
within the virtual learning environment
there is pre-reading for the module
there is the reading list there is study
materials there's activities so for a
couple of weeks prior to the start of
the module
students have the opportunity to
familiarize themselves with what's
coming
for that term in
normal circumstances we would then
formally kick off the term in the module
with two full days of classroom teaching
back to back
now we've had to alter that clearly in
terms of the last 18 months
in relation to the pandemic situation
and we've delivered those programs over
four three-hour sessions over two weeks
and the reason that we've done that is
if i'm completely honest delivering two
full days of teaching
online back-to-back is probably not
going to be a pleasant experience for
anybody
involved and it makes it really
difficult in terms of
the day-to-day distractions of being sat
in front of a screen with phones going
off around you and
children coming home from school and
apologies as i had a moment ago pets
getting involved and barking and making
noises
um so that's why we we took the decision
to break that down into
four three hours sessions so typically
at the moment we would deliver those
full two days of teaching by way of a
three hour session on a tuesday and
thursday
for two weeks it gives the students
the opportunity to account for that time
and
agree that with their employers well in
advance we usually release the
timetables
a good 12 weeks before the sessions
actually start
so there's plenty of uh of headroom in
terms of being able to plan for them
all of the sessions are recorded as well
because we also know that there will
always be
peaks and troughs in workload and issues
that arise at short notice
that will inhibit a student's ability to
attend every single session
wherever possible we encourage it
because it gives the opportunity to have
that live conversation and discussion
about the subject but we do record
everything to ensure that the students
can go back to it
if they haven't been able to meet the
session if they want to utilize it for
a refresher uh in particular students
use it has
used them as study materials as part of
developing their coursework as well
which is really useful and that is one
of the benefits if you like one of the
positives
that has come out of the the kerbin
situation from our perspective
that's also given us the opportunity
where there are particularly difficult
theoretical concepts to get across where
we can lift those out of
a wider session and put something on
specifically to address that
and we actually come to the point where
we identify that during the teaching
so if we get to a point within a taught
session where the group is really
struggling with a particular concept
because of the online practices that we
now have in place
we can literally say right okay well
let's lift that out for now
and we'll put a specific hour on for
that on friday next week
and we would just dedicate time to that
and in doing that
it gives us the opportunity to be much
much more
flexible and responsive to the student
needs and in that sense from the
student's perspective
it's probably not dissimilar to just
booking an appointment in their diary
in the manner that they normally would
so that's been really positive as well
and it's something that we will
definitely be continuing
from september and going into next year
touchwood hopefully
if it's safe and sensible to do so when
we're back in the classroom
um so following the uh the initial
teaching
whether that's two days of block
teaching or the online sessions as i've
just described
we then go into the first seven weeks of
online teaching
we have 10 weeks in total of online
teaching and study materials with
supporting activities that have been
designed and mapped
to the charter management institute
assessment criteria
so each of those activities that the
student undertakes as part of their
online learning
they can put straight into their
portfolio and it gives them the
opportunity to start
marking off assessment criteria that
they've achieved
right from the very beginning of the
program the stud
the online study and the activities are
also facilitated by the module tutor
so feedback is provided as part of that
process individual supports provided as
well as group support within the online
teaching
around week seven we also have a further
full day of teaching
that gives us the opportunity to
consolidate the learning that's been
undertaken that's undertaken in the
previous seven weeks
it gives us the opportunity to outline
and set some teaching up for the
following three weeks for the remaining
three weeks of the year the program
and at that stage as well we also
undertake coursework briefings
so that gives the students the
opportunity to have a really thorough
and in-depth understanding of what the
expectations are
by way of the coursework that they will
submit at the end of the module
are usually around week 12 or 13.
they would then submit their coursework
around week 12 or 13
and the university policy then is is we
have three weeks following that
to take the paperwork through all the
submissions through
internal marketing internal moderation
and then external marking
in anticipation of ratification of the
grades at the assessment board
excuse me thank you andy if you want my
moving on for me
i was just going to mention as as well
that is a vision for the university to
be able to deliver face-to-face elements
of both
management apprenticeships and some
elements of engineering apprenticeships
from our
center latina campus in chesterfield as
well which would
obviously certainly be more accessible
for the
from the northeast derbyshire area as
well so that's one thing that we
really are trying to promote today in
this webinar hopefully
in the future we can deliver cohorts on
management apprenticeships and
engineering from
centerlina thanks andy
okay so andy mentioned briefly about
off-the-job learning
um now there is there is a commitment
requirement it's a mandated requirement
from the government
that uh both the employer and the
student commit to undertake 20
of their working week time in their
training and development
now one of the things that um is a
little bit of a misconception around
that
is that students have to say right from
friday you can't speak to me because i'm
teaching that because i'm undertaking
training development um it doesn't work
like that
principally what we're saying is if if
an individual is working full-time
approximately seven to eight hours a
week has to be developed that has to be
allocated to their training and
development that can incorporate
activities that they undertake with the
university so any teaching lectures
webinars that they undertake
any online any time that they spend on
the online study materials
can count towards the 20 tutorials can
count towards the 20
but as well as that learning and
development that will undertake it that
will be undertaken
within the their employment will also
count towards their 20
of their off the job learning so
training and development that assists
them to develop and grow within their
role within the organization
is completely valid as far as that 20
allocation is concerned
so if they're taking part in shadowing
and mentoring within the workplace and
it's supporting them to develop new
knowledge skills and behaviors
within their role that counts towards
the 20
if for argument's sake an individual is
within
a sales team within the organization
and they have the opportunity to attend
a finance meeting to get a better
understanding
of the relationship between finance and
sales in the organization and how that
team operates
that's completely valid as part of
developing that individual and counting
towards their 20
so the key tests really in terms of
what's valid and eligible as far as the
20
is concerned is is the time spent within
their normal working hours
is the individual undertaking training
and development that can support them in
their knowledge and understanding of
their role
and are they learning new knowledge
skills and behaviors
if those three tests are met it's valid
and eligible as far as that 20
off the job learning is concerned and i
do apologize about my dog now just
getting angry and aggressive and barking
in the background somewhere
thank you andy so in terms of the
support infrastructure then
around both the university and the
employer for apprenticeships
first and foremost every individual
needs to be allocated a work based
mentor
there's a couple of different uh thought
processes on that
some organizations are happy for the
line manager to be the work based mentor
because of the proximity to the student
and the role
and those kinds of things um other
organizations prefer that
the work based mentor is not the line
manager and the principle behind that
really is that the
mentor then not being the line manager
can give the individual
accessibility to other parts of the
organization that they wouldn't
necessarily
be engaged with on a normal day-to-day
basis
within the university we have the
programme lead in this particular case
for the management apprenticeships
that's myself
i'm always accessible and available to
students employers line managers and
mentors
and the first point of contact generally
is the module tutor and the personal
tutor
but everybody has accessibility to my
details and i can be
contacted for really whatever support is
required around
the programs uh every module that we run
has a module tutor clearly and the
module tutor is a subject-specific
expert
in that subject and they are the first
point of contact
in relation to queries and questions
relating to the subject knowledge and
area
they also support all of the online
study materials during that period
every student has allocated a personal
tutor and
our ideal scenario and it does tend to
or it has tended to work so far
our ideal scenario is that the personal
tutor is allocated to the individual and
is with the individual
for the duration of their program the
benefit to that really is that it gives
the personal tutor and the apprentice
the opportunity to really get to know
each other well
you get to understand each other's
working style the approach to the
apprenticeship
and also from the personal tutors
perspective they really get to
understand the individual's job and can
provide the best possible advice
in terms of how to gather and pull
together evidence that presents that
student in the best possible right as
far as
the portfolio of evidence is concerned
we have a team of online learning
advisors the online learning advisors
will support across
all sorts of queries and questions
anything really from
um you know i've been under
a lot of pressure at work and i need an
extension of my deadline for this
particular piece of coursework
right through to i'm having financial
problems and i need to contact wellbeing
support and get some advice
in terms of finance support
and the well-being facilities within the
university are pretty immense if i'm
completely
honest ranging from everything from a gp
practice
through to support advice and guidance
on
mental health finance addiction
just every possible thing that you can
think of really
we have a full it function that will
support with all of the technology
accessibility
um and that will incorporate things like
ensuring that students have
accessibility to
the systems that they have a username
and a logon that they
have their university email address set
up
and that they know how to function and
access those and then also the library
facility
and the library facility again to a
certain degree is multifaceted in the
sense that we have
numerous physical library resources
across the different campuses
but also because of the nature of the
apprenticeship programs we try to ensure
that
the reading materials that we recommend
are accessible as e-resources through
the library
because that means that they're
available 24 hours a day seven days a
week
and it it gives the students the
opportunity to study them
at the best possible time that suits
them so if they're if their window in
the day is that they're working full
time they come home in the evening they
want some family time
to have a meal and to have some time
with kids for argument's sake and they
start studying from nine o'clock at
night until 11 o'clock at night
that suits them best we want to be sure
that they have accessibility to the
materials
at that time and that's why we uh we
tend to
utilize the uh the e-library facilities
as much as possible
and i think i i think there's something
like 50 000 books
available through the e-library
facilities um
so it's pretty comprehensive the
university is also
a member of a network uh called schonel
and schonel is 180 190
university and british libraries across
the uk and with
utilization of the university of derby's
id card
students can access any of those
universities
access books within those universities
and access study space within those
universities
so thinking about locations within
northeast derbyshire
if there is a university closer to where
somebody actually
lives they can attend that library and
utilize the library facilities
at the uh at their local university
rather than feeling they need to
have to make their way down into derby
city centre to be able to utilise the
university of derby campus facilities
thank you andy
oh sorry i'm looking at the wrong screen
didn't realize it moved on
and finally just the process then the
management apprenticeships are
fully fundable through the apprentice
apprenticeship levy scheme
as part of the program students either
have to produce at the
the outset of the program or achieve
during the program
the equivalent of functional skills
level 2 in maths english or a gcse grade
c
if students are able to provide that
certification
we can file that they don't need to do
matter english again
if they can't they will need to
undertake maths in english and there are
i know a number of adult community
learning schemes that they can utilize
for that
but they can also undertake their math
in english at the university of derby as
part of this particular program
as well now unfortunately that also
means
that we are only as i say this is
mandated
by the government as part of the
apprenticeship scheme we are only
allowed to give a buy on the maths in
english
if you can produce physical evidence
that you have those certificate
certificates in place
so unfortunately if you did your gcse
maths in english 25 years ago and you
can't find those certificates and you
can't replace them
you have to attend the functional skills
level too and it is a source of
frustration for a lot of people
but unfortunately it is something that
we have no influence on whatsoever
so i just wanted to make sure that
everybody's clear on that situation
um you can apply for replacement
certificates but it's not particularly
all that cheap i think it's about 40 or
50 pounds
per certificate and that's only really
on the basis
that the uh the government department
can actually find
copies and records of them so
unfortunately if you can't provide the
physical evidence
that you have those you do have to
undertake that training again
as i mentioned there as part of the
procedure in terms of enrolling into the
program we undertake the skill scan
the apprenticeship appendix is part of
the application process
and we also undertake the bksp
diagnostic which every student will do
which again is just looking at matalan
english although if you have your
functional skills level 2
or gcse grade cs in maths and english we
do
again as part of the mandated process
have to look at
how you are developing those skills
within the role that you do and we do
that through the personal tutoring
process
whereby we just look at effectively what
individuals are doing on a day-to-day
basis
and how that provides an opportunity to
continue to develop those skills in the
role
if you have the functional skills on the
gcse grade c
um it's not a mechanism that we continue
to test through the process
we just have to measure and record how
that's happening
and finally in terms of the the
contracts we have the apprenticeship
agreement and commitment statement which
is signed by both the employer
and the uh and the apprentice and that's
really about
uh formalizing that agreement that
everybody's clear of the understandings
of what the apprenticeship
requirements are what the commitments
are that are being made and everybody's
on board and
in agreement so thank you very much
that's all i have for this morning
my details are there and again uh we've
mentioned to uh to maria that we're more
than happy for the
slides to be shared so uh my details
there and these details are there
if you do have any questions or queries
following up from this and
once you've had a chance to reflect on
what we've spoken about this morning
please do get in touch
thank you thanks verge
thank you thank you very much andy and
spencer that was absolutely amazing to
to see and hear and it's i'm very happy
that we get to
spread a bit awareness about these
apprenticeship but about the wide
variety
that there is about the wonderful
support and the absolutely
like amazingly flexible delivery of
these these apprenticeships and
now actually um to tell us about the
benefits of handling apprenticeships
from the business side
from the business perspective we have
lee barnes managing director
at inspire design so uh lee over to you
hello good morning i'm lee barnes
managing director of inspired design and
development
and i just want to talk a little bit
this morning
about how my business has benefited
from using the apprenticeship scheme
we are consulting engineers based in
play cross
we specialize in the delivery of
infrastructure for new development sites
of which north east derbyshire has
plenty currently
um we employ engineers and technicians
varying levels
as well as town and country planners and
of course the back office staff required
to deliver a successful business
as a small practice um competing
in the employment market against much
larger often
international consultancies can be a
real challenge for us
um geographically we're competing with
practices from
sheffield nottingham and derby and
there's a lot of competition there in
those cities
we have managed to successfully recruit
a candidate
creating the opportunities for that team
member
to advance their knowledge and
experience is key to helping them
fulfill
not only their potential but achieve
their own personal goals
but training team members is a
expensive undertaking there's the cost
of the course
the cost of the time off the loss of
productivity
well that's one way of looking at it
anyway we prefer to see it as an
investment
in the business it's an investment in
the future of the business an
investment in the future of our team and
to quote
sir richard branson train people well
enough
so they can leave treat them well enough
so they don't want to
that's what we try and do here
so providing opportunities for people to
grow and advance
helps to provide fulfillment and
satisfaction within their roles
to assist in upskilling the team we
utilize the
apprenticeship scheme extensively at all
levels but the area
where we're seeing the greatest impact
on the business is where we have people
undertaking degree level apprenticeships
and we currently have two undertaking
degree level
apprenticeships out of the team of 10 we
have an aspiring engineer
who joined us with a hnc qualification
and a good amount of practical
experience as well said
upon joining us we identified him as
having a high degree of
potential to move on within his career
although he did like a little bit of
confidence
we spoke to him about his career
aspirations and we set him up on the
civil engineering
degree program with the university of
derby as
andy previously mentioned since then
we've noticed
a marked difference in how he operates
within the business
he has become more confident his
knowledge base is broadened
and he started to become a really good
role model and mentor for the younger
team members
the course also offers a direct route
to achieving a professional
qualification through the institution of
civil engineers
which would be a significant industry
recognize benchmark
that is not only a feather in the camp
for the candidate himself but it
increases the credibility of my business
by
increasing the number of professionally
recognized individuals within the
organization
this candidate also knows that upon
successful completion of this course
it will lead to him moving into a more
senior role within the team so he's got
that goal that benchmark to aim for
the other team member on a degree level
apprenticeship
isn't an engineer at all she is
currently my
sales and marketing manager and she does
a great job in that role
we identified her as being a natural
leader with a fabulous work ethic
so in this instance i'm thinking about
succession planning for my own role so i
don't know about you guys but i don't
intend working forever
there's an awful lot of beaches out
there that i haven't laid on yet
once the world is fixed i intend to go
on and do so
so um for the purposes of gdpr we will
just call this candidate gemma
because it sounds a little bit
impersonal calling a
candidate the gem has undertaken a
chartered management degree level
apprenticeship
in business management and leadership
and she's been able to apply much of
what she's done in the business
to the topic she's covering on the
course and vice versa
so there's been a a really useful
transfer of knowledge there
i've seen gemma start to develop really
good
all-round understanding of all the
different facets of
business and leadership there's only so
much learning i can pass on from my
experience especially as i'm self-taught
so having the opportunity to access
formal education
is a real bonus for me as a as a
business owner
and as a business owner who has a keen
eye for managing budgets to protect
profit margins i cannot speak highly
enough
of the opportunities that higher degree
level apprenticeships program
has unlocked for our business in terms
of being able to upskill our staff
it has facilitated my desire to provide
opportunities for my team members
to grow as my business grows and for
them to benefit from that by becoming
well
qualified confident professionals
it's helped me provide opportunities to
team members that
hadn't had one for one reason or another
or did not have the opportunity to go
into education higher education
previously
my passion to provide opportunity to
those who previously
hadn't had access to a degree course
stems from my own experience
i didn't enter the industry by the
traditional route of
doing a levels and then a full-time
degree course
i did a vtec qualification at
chesterfield college
a long time ago now longer than a
kettlebell
and then i managed to get a job at
derbyshire county councils
after after eight years or so of working
i decided to advance my career
and i was able to start a part-time
degree whilst working freelance
again not everybody else has the
opportunity to fund that themselves
rather
or they're freelancing so the
degree level apprenticeship route
provides that pathway to a professional
career for people
who maybe don't have the opportunity for
whatever reason whether that be social
or economic
or some people just don't mature
academically until later in life i
certainly fit that description
so in summary from my perspective as a
business owner
and as someone who is passionate about
providing alternative pathways to a
professional career
in civil engineering higher and degree
level apprenticeships are a valuable
resource
an affordable way to upskill
my team and grow my own engineers
they are facilitating our goal to punch
above our weight in the
market and create opportunities for our
team to grow as the business grows
i also found it creates loyalty within
the team
and we get longevity of employment
within
within the guys that work for us we we
don't have a high turnover staff at all
so i think i've spoken long enough now
and i'll happily hand back to our host
but i just want to
thank you for the opportunity to tell
you how we have benefited
from the apprenticeships program and i
would encourage all of you to grasp the
opportunities that are there in front of
you
thank you thank you very much lee that
was
it was wonderful it's amazing it's
absolutely great to hear how much of a
good
impact such a program can have on a
business and how well it's integrated
within the business how
how many benefits it has for the
business as well as the individual their
career and in the long term for both
it's uh wonderful uh i think this about
rounds up for our webinar for today as a
final point
i will uh invite everybody present if
they have any questions at all
drop them in the chat or just unmute
yourself it's
fine and we hope to pick them up um
if there's nothing at all after this
this seems like possibly a a good
a good stop point for the recording for
this session